I'm Jenna Fisher and I'm Angela Kinsey.
We were on The Office together and we're best friends.
And now we're doing the ultimate Office Lovers podcast just for you.
Each week we will dive deeper into the world of the office with exclusive interviews
behind the scenes details and lots of BFF stories.
We're the Office Lady 6.0.
Hi everyone.
Howdy?
We can't believe we're saying this, but I mean.
Really, truly.
We're fan-girling because.
You guys, Billy Eilish is back on the podcast today.
By her request.
She reached out to us.
I mean, lady, maybe we're cool.
We're 100% cool now.
We are now, yeah.
It's official.
Well, listen, she is an incredible person.
She was in the studio with us today.
She also brought along her dog shark.
And she talks about some of her favorite all-time moments from the office.
those were just so amazing to hear.
She really knows the show.
She knows the show.
I mean, there are this super office fandom group
that they know the show backwards and forwards.
They can quote the show.
They know the world.
They love the world.
And Billy is in that group of people.
Yes.
And I loved talking about her favorite moments with her.
And we also talked about her new live concert movie,
which just came out.
hit me hard and soft in 3D, a movie that she co-directed with James Cameron.
She tells us about that.
And Billy wanted to do another round of trivia.
Yes, because the first time she was on the podcast, we did office trivia.
She kicked our butts.
Yes.
Yeah.
So this time she enlisted her friend Jack, who called in, and we tried to think of some of just the hardest deep cut questions.
And wow.
Well, you'll hear how it goes.
Mm-hmm. So without further ado, please enjoy our conversation with the awesome Billy Eilish.
All right, you guys, we're so excited because Billy Eilish is here with us today.
Yes.
Hi, Billie. This is so great. Hi, guys. I begged them let me back on the show, so here I am back on the show.
Billy, we're not even believe you want to hang out with us, truly.
I called Cameron, who's sitting over there, and I was like, hey, I know office ladies are at that.
You know, I already went on. I had my time, but can I go back?
Can I please go back on?
And I have so many things to say, and I'm going to get into it.
But I'm so happy to be here right now.
It was the most exciting email ever.
I was in a dressing room at the mall, and I yelped.
You did not.
I did.
I was like, ah!
And then I immediately am side texting Angela.
Angela, check your email.
And I was driving, so I'm like, I can't see the email.
What is it?
Yeah.
We're very excited to have you.
Well, I have one thing to say that is really, really crazy to hear.
hear myself say and the fact that it's true.
Shark stop it.
Shark's here.
Shark is here.
Yeah, he's crying in the corners.
But I obviously was nervous last time I came because it's you guys and it's the office,
which is like my oxygen.
And there's that.
But today I have to tell you something, which is that I listen to office ladies more than I
watch the office.
I'm out.
That is amazing.
More, and by the way, I have listened to every single episode of your entire podcast.
You're kidding me. Stop it.
By the way, because I'm obviously obsessed with you in this incredible show that has changed my life forever.
Like, I've seen the show so many times that I know what I'm watching.
And I listened to obviously these, like I'm, I listen to it as soon as I wake up, when I get ready for the day, when I get dressed, when I'm driving, when I'm packing, when.
when I'm cleaning.
I listen to it every single night to fall asleep,
every single night,
and I have listened to every single episode,
except like when you talk about, like, Star Wars.
I'm sorry.
You have to listen to Star Wars.
It's really craptastic.
Okay, the holiday.
Star Wars movie, though, is so bad.
It's so good.
We won't do the other ones.
Okay, but I had to just say
that I now listen to your podcast more than
watch the office. And just so you know, to give you context, I've never done anything more than
watch the office. Because I started listening, like, after we did our podcast, and then I've listened
to every single episode you guys have put out since 2019, God damn it. And literally up until I am 29
minutes into second drink of employee transfer, which you put out 13 hours ago. So I'm fully up to
date. I am dying. Every single episode. Hearing both of your voices right now is like very confusing
for me because I hear them every day all day like this, not in the office, like this.
And Sam being here, I'm like, Sam, I feel like I know so much about you, Sam.
Because weren't you here when I was here?
Yes.
Because like I didn't even think.
Sam is day one.
That's insane.
I mean, I know that now.
From airwulfs with us.
But I don't, I was like, oh, hey, Sam.
You know, when I met you the first time and now I have all this lore about you, Sam.
And I'm like, I know all about Cassie.
and I'm like, I just, I know everything, and I am as much a fan of office ladies as I am of the office.
And so, yeah, anyway, that's my thing.
That's my spiel.
And that's why I needed to get the hell in here.
Well, first of all, I'm speechless, which is rare, because that was so sweet.
And I'm going to live on that for a long time.
Well, are you still watching the office at all?
I'm still watching the office, but I watch the office now more as like a TV thing.
because it used to be my podcast.
Like, it used to be a...
You used to listen to it inside.
I'm like in your pocket.
Yes, I would put it in my pocket.
Yeah.
I mean, I still do that.
I did that last night.
I've been like putting up frames on my walls and like putting up pictures and I've been like drilling them into the walls.
And so I put my phone in my pocket and I'm like, I'm carrying things around my house.
And usually it used to be the office playing because I know what it looks like.
I just need to hear it to like visualize it because I have it all memorized.
And now it's you guys.
I watch The Office now as a little dessert, like a little gift to myself.
It's more of a watching TV than it used to be.
Are you still going in order?
Or do you jump around now?
I still go in order.
I can't really jump around because I'm watching the super fan episodes.
I was going to ask you that.
Are you watching them?
Of course.
I mean, I think Dave Rogers, you know.
Dave Rogers, absolutely.
He's like done an amazing job.
Amazing job.
I think it was fun run that the deleted scenes were so.
amazing. That's on his list of his 10 favorites. It's amazing. And the whole episode, I was like,
these are so good. Yeah. And then, yeah, there's like some episodes with so many deleted scenes where
you're like, whoa. Whoa. Yeah. Interesting. And like deleted scenes are just little snippets of
moments that he finds that are nonverbal. I love. Like so good. So good. Like, so many more like
looks around like people like clocking what Michael's doing or whatever. Also, like you have said this about
the super fan episodes that is what one thing that's so interesting is so many of the scenes that
are added are the scenes in the shots that were in the original episode but like lengthened on either
side yeah yeah where it's like you didn't even know there was more to that scene that you've seen
forever which has been like really amazing so i'm currently i've watched everything but season
nine because those just came out so i'm about to start season nine of the super fan episodes but i keep like
going back to the beginning and then like if people are watching with me, I will go to like season
four because it's just so good that it's undeniable just to make sure everyone knows how incredible
it is.
So yeah.
I'm rewatching with my kids.
So this will be my second rewatch.
Amazing.
We are in the middle of season five.
I can't remember where we just ended.
but I really love season four and five.
They're unbeatable.
They are so good.
Like, goodbye Toby.
When I knew that Michael was going to do his song,
I didn't even watch the TV.
I just watched my kids.
Because I love it when he's like,
he's out of here.
Toby's going away.
Like I love it.
See ya.
I love it.
Oh, my God.
it's so good. Yeah. It's so exciting, too, that your kids get to relive it with you and also
see this thing that is on camera forever that you get to watch. It's just amazing. And then
their kids will be able to watch. Oh, my gosh. That's crazy to be about it. It is wild, and we've
talked about this, and you've probably heard me say this, but when your kids' friends who have always
known you is just like Isabel's mom, and then all of a sudden you're Angela Martin to them, and they're
like, whoa, what?
I'm like, you guys want a snack?
And they're like, you're just like, it's really wild.
It's so wild.
It just, because it just, the view changes.
It's like me with Sam.
I'm like, wait, Sam is here?
I know so much about Sam.
You have to say hi.
Hi.
Hi, Sam.
I know your voice so well.
It's good to meet you again.
Wow.
Amazing.
This is insane.
And this is how all fans of office ladies specifically feel is like,
Like, you guys are with me through everything.
Like, everything I'm going through, at least I have you guys.
And what's really been crazy is I was in my house.
I was, like, cleaning something or, you know, this is a while ago.
This is when I was like halfway through all of your episodes.
And I hear like, oh, by the way, Billy Eilish said, did it.
And I went like, because I'm like, I forgot for a second.
You just broke your phone for a wall.
Whoa.
And then that happened multiple.
times. And then because I'm letting them play and play and play, I have them all in my queue. So I'm not
looking at which one is coming next. And so then it's like, guess who's here today? And then my
voice appears and I hear, hi, guys. And I'm like sitting in my living room. Oh my God. Like, it's the
most trippy thing because obviously I experienced doing that with you guys. But I literally am Isabel's
friends. Like I feel like I have this whole new like view of it. And it's just the most insane.
same thing in the world. Oh, God. Well, okay, first of all, last time you're here, we said you can come
back anytime. That invitation stands. So anytime, here I am. Correct. And we be careful what you
for, seriously. Well, we wanted to talk to you about some of your favorite The Office moments.
And you actually said there's almost so many. There's so many. But we were going to try to narrow it down to
three today. Okay. We can try. Well, that is a really hard question. I like,
spent the whole week, like, writing down everything and, like, scrolling through every episode
to, like, make sure that I had the right ones. Okay, so I'm going to try to narrow it down.
First of all, one of the most incredible scenes. Oh, God. Okay, wait, I'm going to say two and one
because they're similar. I literally can see your brain, like, going through a Rolodex.
No, actually Rolodex brain right now, because I have so many. Okay. Jenna.
Yes. God damn it.
Two scenes that are absolutely some of the most incredible acting I've ever seen in my life
and undeniably the most incredible between you and John acting that's ever been given to us
as a people in the world.
Specifically when he confesses that he's in love with you,
that is one of the most groundbreaking scenes to me and like iconic.
and it's such a basic answer
because it's such an amazing scene.
Everything about it is so special
and on that same note,
jumping ahead,
when you do your talking head
when he's doing his interview for Stamford,
you know you killed that whole...
I feel like if I were you,
I would be like, yeah, that was pretty fucking good.
That was pretty good.
Of any moment on the office,
that is like my best moment.
And I know it.
Like I know.
You better know it.
Pretty great.
Like everything that comes across your face is just phenomenal.
And also not only do you know it, but Ken Kwapas knew it too.
Yeah.
And he's just everyone.
Everyone knew it.
It's obvious.
Can I tell you that I was scrolling Instagram recently and someone posted that the reason
I gave that performance was because I didn't know John was going to come in the door
and deliver that line?
When they make that stuff up.
And it's not true, everybody.
I knew it was in the script.
It was meticulously timed.
But not only that, she had to do that take multiple times.
Yeah.
Of course.
She knew he was coming.
I knew he was coming.
No shit.
You're just an amazing actor.
Yeah.
You know, everyone loves him.
Of course he's going to get the job.
And, you know, we never got the timing right.
I shot him down.
He did the same to me.
But it's fine.
Everything's going to be.
And you turn.
And there he is.
Are you free for dinner?
tonight, you go yes, and he says it's a date. You turn back to the camera and your eyes have
filled with tears. I don't know how I did it. I don't know. I did it either. Like, how did you do that?
When I turned back, the look on Ken Kwapis's face, he was next to the camera. He was our director
for that episode. He looked at me. It's insane. He'd been with us since the pilot. He felt like our
dad and like having that moment where your dad is like, you did it, kid. You know when something
means something to you, it's really moving. But when you can lock eyes with someone who knows
just as well what it means to you, then you lose it. And so the fact that the Pam inside of me
was getting all of her wishes come true in that moment, but then I could look in the eyes of someone
else who knew that all of Pam's wishes were coming true. That is what did it. If I had
to look at a tennis ball, I can't say that you would have gotten the same thing.
So there was like, there was another performance happening off camera that was helping me.
It's just so amazing. And when you did that, I mean, because you had to do multiple takes.
I don't understand how one can recreate this. Also, because it's not like, you know,
a scene where you're starting it out crying. It's like that's a whole other hard thing.
But it's like doing the same scene over and over where you're starting out totally normal and unaffected and then switching over.
It's just like so amazing.
And I just can't give you enough props.
It's just so magical and you're so incredible.
Thank you.
I actually think it's easier to do starting to not cry and to crying because if the writing is right and if you know your character, then the truth of it should make the emotion come.
I've had to do scenes.
Like I had to do that scene where I'm just like sobbing in the hallway and then Dwight comes up to me.
It was so much harder to get myself to that state from zero, from nothing.
That's crazy.
That's when you have to like listen to sad music and like all that.
And like stay away from everyone between scenes doing bits.
Right.
And I know that everyone kind of left you alone and let you have that to fully get into it.
And it's just so amazing and moving.
And I'm also obsessed with that your song.
to get you, I think then
it was the, please, please,
let me get what I want cover by...
Who was it, Deftones or something insane?
I think that's right, yeah.
That's an insane choice, Jenna.
It's an amazingly insane, amazing.
Like, by the way,
please, please, please, let me get what I want
by the Smiths is an incredible song
and it is so heartbreaking.
And when you said that, I thought,
wow, that's an amazing choice.
And I thought, oh, I haven't heard Deftones version.
I listen to it.
And it's like
And I'm like so hard.
Jeff, hell yeah.
That's just I love
because music does have that effect.
This one is a metal head.
It's amazing.
Yeah.
My son is.
And so by default,
I have now,
it's amazing.
It's just so magical.
And okay,
moving it along because I have more,
I have more moments.
That was like one and a halfish of.
Yeah.
There was a lot of moments.
I'm just saying, really.
Okay.
In my most recent rewatch, because I'm listening to you guys talk about each episode,
I'm really watching them more closely now because now I know so much behind the scenes of it,
which is so fun and interesting and exciting.
And Angela, you just are just gold to the show.
It's just like the amount of times that we watch this show, and I'm like, wait for it.
And then you just say something with the most perfect.
Delivery. And it's so interesting because I know how different you are from Angela Martin.
And now you're not that cold, you know, you're this bubbly angel of a person. And it is pretty
upsetting how incredible you are at playing that kind of a character. And I know that you talked about
how you've always kind of before that played like a beat and fun light characters. And like on New Girl,
you're like, yeah, okay, you know, just this like light kind of owly.
You have owl eyes, like what you say in there.
Anyway, moving on.
So I feel like I know you so well now based on this show.
And it's just even more impressive.
And like, okay, specific lines of yours that kill me and that we quote all the time is like
when Michael is in the bullpen and he's trying to.
to kind of derail everyone from knowing that some of them aren't going to get raises or that all
the raises are going to be smaller. And he's like, yes, lend Oscar a cup of sugar. And you go,
what are you talking about, Michael? It's literally like the most incredible delivery of a line ever in
life. Also, like, the amount of times that you, like, in the conference room just add like an, oh.
And it just, it always makes me laugh out loud.
And your ability to be so cruel is uncanny and unbelievable and so moving.
And also like just every time like Kevin pushes by you and you completely fall, it's just, it kills me.
I'm like getting flustered and I'm trying to think of like more specific moments.
Wait, I have them written down.
Please.
Hold on.
You mentioned crime aid.
Oh, my gosh.
Freaking.
Crime aid.
Your favorite moment from crime aid, I love so much that I asked Matt Beagle and Sam to pull it as a clip if we wanted to hear it.
Because it's that thing.
You love something that we both love is when Michael doesn't know what he's saying, but he's trying to make a point.
And he's just meandering all over the place.
This is one of my favorite Michael moments of all time because Steve Correll, just anything that comes out of
his mouth is gold. And really like every line of his is my favorite of the entire show. And
specifically like what you're saying, when he's like, sometimes I just start a sentence.
The dual? And I just hope I find it. I just don't know where it's going, but just maybe I'll find it
along the way. That's one of my favorite things in the world. And you can just see that happen
over and over and over. Imagine this. You're in the conference room with us. I can't even.
Steve is going to have a meandering speech, and then he just starts freestyling it, like just throwing in some extra random thoughts.
And that would be it.
I'd be like, I can't even handle it.
All right, all right.
Well, let's listen.
Okay.
So in order to recoup the value of items we liked, we have to spend more money on things we don't want.
Who would ever come to this?
I don't know.
It could be any number of people.
It could be a pedestrian.
It could be a loopie loo.
It could be a Lukie Lou.
Or it could be a Bruce Springsteen fan.
What?
Who said that?
I did.
Well, why did I say that?
Oh, I think you know why I said that.
I think it's very apparent.
I think it goes without saying, bear with me.
There's a point there.
But what is the point?
I don't understand what he's saying.
It seems a little shady.
It seems a little foggy.
Oh, my gosh.
Well, it's not a little foggy.
There's really something going on.
Do you need us for any of this?
Do I?
Do you need us for?
ready at this.
Do I?
Oh my God, that kills me.
Another really quick moment
that is like that
when he's like,
the head of a monkey
and the body.
That's the moment
I could not recover from.
Because he just started throwing
out all kinds of animal combinations
that weren't scripted.
And it just goes way too long.
Also, there's like long pauses.
So you're like,
what animal is he can say?
Yes.
We don't know.
It's just the most amazing thing.
His brain just works
in a way that I just don't understand.
One other moment that I just remember just now
is one of my all-time favorites
is when Ed Truck dies.
And he's like, it feels like
someone dropped, I think,
my soul or my heart into a bucket of boiling tears.
And then someone else comes in
and starts, you know, punching me in the grief bone.
And he's just like making stuff up.
but then it just always ends up being so heartbreaking and touching.
I know.
And it just kills me.
Anyway, I could literally go on forever.
I mean, it's interesting that you two are the ones with this podcast because obviously you two
are best friends and you're such hard workers and you make this show because it's a passion
of yours.
But you happen to be two of the most important parts of this show, The Office, and two of the
greatest actresses I've ever seen. And your performances in this show specifically are just so
incredible and just having it be you to is just really special. And everyone in the office is
incredible. But it's just, I don't know, I think I've just been more aware, I think,
recently of how incredible you are and noticing it throughout and just being like, wow, I
can't believe how good Angela is. Anyway, let me stop. Well, I mean. Just take it in. Just let me say it and take it. I'm just trying to take it. I'm trying to take it. Before we move on, I do want to talk about your love of Michael's birthday because you mentioned that. My mother was rubbing cream on me for probably three hours.
Those talking heads. I mean, we were just talking about how it's like there's these talking heads and they're like funny, but they're also like, oh, Michael, particularly when he's talking about.
about his childhood or his family.
Oh, God, I can't.
I know.
So, I can't deal with it.
But you found a candy bag all for Michael's birthday.
So you know, Michael has these talking heads about his worst birthdays.
Yes.
So here's one that was in the script, but was not used.
Michael would say, on my 20th birthday, my supposed a best friend, Sam Ambrose,
ditched me for his twin sister's sweet 16 party like I didn't want to go.
That was my worst birthday until today.
It's that whole runner of it being his worst birthday.
It's just, they're all so, so tough to listen.
You're like, oh, I know, I know.
Well, not to make it worse, but I did ask Matt to pull,
this is from the super fan of the surplus.
And this is a deleted scene.
No, it's not a worst birthday.
It's just about his childhood.
Oh, gosh.
Okay.
Okay, let's listen.
I would like to tell you a little story.
about a boy named...
That doesn't even matter.
Could be any one of you.
And like any other 12-year-old boy,
he wanted a pippy long-stocking doll for Christmas.
But his evil stepfather, Jeff said,
no, you may not have what you want.
You must have a football.
And the boy cried, and he cried, and he cried,
and he held his breath as long as he could,
and he wouldn't eat his dinner.
But you know something?
It turns out that Jeff was right.
Because I already had a G.I. Joe and a Stretch Armstrong, and a Malibu Barbie, and a Major Matt Mason,
which technically is enough for a tea party.
So my point is this.
I didn't need what I thought I needed.
What I needed was to learn how to appreciate what I had.
Which in this case was enough dollars to have tea with.
Exactly.
Got it.
Now.
Oh, God.
Jeff. It's always Jeff.
Always Jeff.
Another one like that that I just thought of too
is when Jim says, just make fun of yourself
and then they won't make fun of you after he falls in a lake.
And he's like, actually, it's not the first time I fell into it.
Like, the girls used to throw me in a lake.
And when he's telling it and then he's like,
everyone's like starting to get uncomfortable, like,
oh, this is actually kind of a deep-rooted trauma thing.
It's not actually funny.
And then he goes, too far!
He says too far and he has this like frog in his throat.
And he's like, thanks.
Thanks a lot, Jim.
Thanks for the advice.
It just kills me.
I just can't even deal with that.
And then also I have a couple written down,
except I didn't write them down.
I put them all in voice notes.
So I'm reading all the transcription of my insane ramblings.
So wait, you're rambling into your phone, your favorite one is?
Yeah, because I was trying to like, this is a really hard one for me.
Like this is a hard question for me.
But the last one that I thought of was in weight loss when he's like,
Kelly and I are the only ones who've either pass out or almost pass out, and he does this flapping.
Yes, I know it.
Yes.
And that is so amazing.
It just, oh, God.
And it's just so clearly just him.
Yes.
And it's so exactly how we feel as people.
Like, it's just like the most like childlike tantrum flap.
Yeah.
That just every time he does that, it makes me laugh out loud.
And then also.
Okay, wait.
Jerk, are you dreaming?
That one got him.
He's like really...
He's looking really pig-like right now,
just for everyone wondering.
The other one was like, just, I mean,
prison Mike is just the most iconic thing in the world.
And also specifically, I love
that John in the background is like kind of breaking,
but my favorite part of him breaking
is I like the idea that it's actually Jim laughing
at what Michael is doing
because one thing
that I've always thought
about the office
is of course
the humor at the beginning
of more is like
so dry
and it's like
no one laughs, right?
And Michael is doing
so many things to you
specifically in the first season
that is like
you're just like
looking at him deadpan
and not laughing
and I feel like
the one thing
that I've always thought
is throughout the show
the amount of things
that are so ridiculous and so, like, unironically funny,
I would laugh out loud at in real life.
And, like, the fact that Jim is dying, laughing at Michael doing this prison mic thing,
I think is so real.
Because wouldn't you laugh at this guy doing that in front of you?
Like, especially if you're with your friends and, you know, you're not supposed to laugh.
And you're not supposed to laugh.
And so whenever anyone breaks, I'm like, that is so real.
though, because in real life, somebody doing something as ridiculous as that you would laugh
without even meaning to, even if you're not supposed to. And I love those moments so much.
Anyway, I have to cut myself off because I'm going to keep going. Okay.
What of everything you learn in history class was only half the story? I'm Dr. Hrini-Bot,
host of hidden history. Every Monday, I go where history gets mysterious. Vanished civilizations,
doomsday prophecies, paranormal phenomena, and events that science
Still can't fully explain.
On Hidden History, I treat these moments like open case files.
Not Miss, not superstition, just incomplete explanations waiting for a closer look.
Listen to and follow Hidden History, available now wherever you get your podcast.
Well, we also want to hear about your movie.
Yes, that's coming out.
It's a big deal.
This is amazing.
Okay, so by the time everyone hears this, the movie will be out because it came out on May 8th.
Yes.
It's hit me hard and soft the tour.
You co-directed it with James Cameron.
In 3D.
It's true.
I mean, I saw the trailer.
I already have tickets.
I can't wait to see it.
It's part of my daughter's birthday present.
I'm taking her on a friend.
Yes.
Oh, my God.
We've got a whole moms and daughters crew.
We'll be filling up two different theaters.
Okay.
But yeah, tell us about it.
It looks so great.
It looks like you're giving people a lot of access, too.
Real behind the scenes.
Yeah, that was like not planned and kind of came about naturally.
And I at first was very like, no, I don't want to do that.
Because I was filmed from when I was 15 to when I was 18 for this documentary that was made, which was an amazing experience.
But like, a lot of my life was filmed.
And I kind of have this like, oh, no, I'm good.
Like, I don't know if I, you know.
And so when it came about, I was like, oh, I would love to capture this show.
First of all, it's my favorite show I've ever created, and I had such an amazing time on the tour, and just in general, that show is like my best work.
Like, I just feel like you in that scene.
Like, I'm like, yeah, you know what?
I will agree.
This is my best work.
I feel very proud.
So I felt really excited about that, but at first I was like, I don't want to do any behind-the-scenes stuff.
I don't want to make it like a documentary of any kind because I don't want to share too much.
And honestly, Jim, James Scarrant, Jim.
Jim.
He agreed, by the way.
But then when we were kind of moving through it, he was like, what if we just like talked and filmed it?
And I was kind of like, I don't know.
And it just came so naturally.
And also beyond being naturally happening, it was also like I saw the importance of it.
And I thought, you know what?
this is the reality of me and my show.
And it's like, yeah, if we're going to be showing this show that I've worked so hard on,
let's show the experience of doing that and what is my day like leading up to it.
And also, like, the fans haven't seen that in a while.
And I thought that it would be really fun for them too.
And also in 3D, I mean, I would have loved to have seen my favorite artist when I was young in 3D
because I could have felt like I was there.
and I was in front of them.
And it's been a really intense and long and grueling process
of making it and editing it and working on every aspect of it.
But it's now I can feel, I feel like really,
because I feel really good about it.
And I think it's really good.
And I'm really, really excited.
I can't wait.
I'm really excited.
You know, there's this great quote that has something to do with like,
one of the greatest gifts as an artist that you can give other artists
is to show your brush strokes.
Yeah.
because we so often just put out, like, you just see the final thing.
And so I feel like with this movie, we're going to get to see some of the brushstrokes.
We're going to see how the whole thing comes together.
Yeah.
My daughter just admires you so much.
And I love that she's going to see someone that she idolizes, like, doing all the work to get to the big moment on stage.
Right.
And then also.
Yeah, that's true.
I didn't even think of that.
It's just really cool, you know?
It's like a really valuable gift.
that you're giving.
Yeah.
So thank you.
I mean, I always love the final product.
The process is what always just like tugs at my heartstrings because you see how much work it really is.
And it's so important to see the work that you put into something.
It's really true.
Yeah.
That's really true.
I hadn't really thought about that.
And it's really true because I think like it's so easy to see a final product and be like, well, that it was perfect from the start.
And it just wasn't.
And also, like, you know, even though this movie, we didn't.
until I was already way into the tour.
And, you know, I had been doing the show for a while.
And it was kind of perfect at that point in terms of, like, process.
But we had filmed, like, we had, just to have, we'd filmed a little bit of the beginning
of the tour.
And also specifically, like, the night before, and it's in the movie somewhat, but the
night before we started filming, I sprained my ankle, which I hadn't done in six years.
I used to do all the time, and literally I was in Manchester to film the movie.
I had this meeting with Jim.
I went to my hotel, and I immediately sprained mangled by stepping out onto my balcony, which was a two-inch drop.
You're so athletic in your concerts, but it was like stepping on the balcony.
Yes, that's what did it.
And so I, the next day started one of many, many shows in a row being filmed in 3D with a sprained ankle.
And I was like, you know what?
This gives me a challenge.
I love a challenge.
I'm going to do it.
I'm going to, you know, and I think like really what the movie is about, aside from, you know, the fact that this tour and this show is so special for me and I want everyone to see it and the fact that the tour ended and not everyone in the entire world got to watch it is I feel so grateful and lucky that people who didn't get to come are going to get to see it and feel like they were there.
also people who did get to see it and want to relive it and specifically, selfishly, that I will forever get to watch this and have it.
Yes.
It's so special, I think, to have any kind of visual or oral history of something that meant a lot to you.
And we have that with our podcast.
We think about that all the time.
Yeah.
Yeah, we've said now, we've gotten on record, every memory and story, minus the ones we're saving for office ladies,
to the ground.
Yeah.
We have them out there now.
Girl, we're all ready for that one.
We are all ready for that.
But it's like in the,
literally in the office,
when Phyllis says, like,
I worked here for this long
and I never wrote anything down.
You know, we all think like,
oh, I'll remember that forever.
And you just won't.
And like, if it's filmed,
and like, you guys,
like, this is recorded forever.
Like, you're going to have this forever to listen to
to and you have the office forever to watch.
Like, it's just such a gift.
And I feel, honestly, before Jim reached out to us, me, through my mother, he sent an email to my mom.
Literally, that's how it happened.
Amazing.
I was like, I didn't have any plans to film the show because I wasn't going to make a concert film of any kind.
And I was already feeling like, damn, that sucks.
Like, this is such an important show to me.
And no one's ever going to be able to, like, watch it.
And the movie really is about the fans.
Like the real truth is that it's all about the fans and my feeling of devotion to them and their feeling of that with me and our love.
And like, honestly, similar to the office.
It's like, what am I without my fans, you know?
And it's like, what is the office without the fans?
It's just, it's all this one big.
Absolutely, the community.
The community of it.
And that's my favorite thing in the world.
I wouldn't do any of this if it weren't for that, you know?
It's a really cool thing.
The openness and the like human to human thing that happens, like when we meet someone and they are telling us how much the office means to them, that is such a gift to me that I get to be part of this thing that brought that other person, this joy or whatever.
So it's like it's such a really cool connection.
It's really cool.
And like, you know, this is like, I know, like an intense subject.
but like what you were saying about sharing your process.
That made me think of like your health journey, Jenna,
and how what you said on the podcast about like,
this is a really intense, scary thing to be going through.
And you have totally the right to be like,
I'm never speaking about it.
I'm never talking about it.
Please don't ask me about it.
And instead, because you have said on this podcast,
about how like sharing your experience might help other people and other people who are experiencing
this. And that is such an amazing gift. And the amount of people that I think you sharing your
health journey with like changed their lives and made them feel seen and like they're not alone. And
that's just really special. And you don't have to do that yet you do. And I think like that's
obviously like completely a different thing than the stupid little movie I'm doing.
But it just made me think of that.
And I just wanted to verbalize to you, like, you don't owe anyone anything.
And yet, you're so giving.
And it's just so magical.
And, like, sharing your story with people just to help them is so selfless and so kind.
And, yeah, I just had to say that.
Well, thank you.
You know, it is a fine line.
It's like there's always that question of how much do I share and how much do I keep for
myself. Sometimes, you know, when I start sharing about breast cancer, I have to think about
breast cancer. And I'm pretty excited to not think about it. So there's that. But the thing is,
is that any time I've had a person tell me that they got checked because they heard my story
or they found something early enough to do something about it because they got checked because
they heard my story, it means so much to me. Like, it means so much to me. But yet, even still,
I do pick my moments. And I think that it's okay to pick your moments of access. Like,
you don't have to give everything. But, you know, there's a balance there. And I think that's as an
artist, I think we're always trying to find that balance, which is like, how much do I have to
keep for myself? Also, in order to do my art, I don't know about you. But, like,
Like, there's a certain amount of, like, process that I get into superstitious thinking.
And if I share too much, then it doesn't work.
Yeah.
And also, like, again, not that just what you were saying made me think of how much I look up to you and how much everyone looks up to you.
And I'm in no way trying to compare it the two or your experience and your journey with anything in the entire world.
Because it's like.
But you're talking about sharing.
But I'm just talking about in general.
No, when you get.
Sharing is so.
Sharing.
you put yourself out there.
You're vulnerable.
Every time you share no matter what it is, you're sharing.
And in life, whether you're like a junior in high school and you decide to share your essay in front of the class or you're, I don't know, a nurse at the hospital and you share like the crocheted sweater you made.
I don't know.
Anyway, this is like a Michael Scott analogy.
I am turning into Michael Scott we've discovered.
But I do think every time you share as a person, you're stepping out there.
Rewarded.
Yeah. And it's like, it's just, we must not forget that sharing saves lives.
Like, it saves lives. And like, it's just, it's easy to be like, uh, no, no. And you know what?
You don't have to also. You don't ever have to. You don't have to. You get to decide. And the one thing I will say, you know, about the office and about your concerts and going to concerts like that.
My daughter went to this concert with her friends and saw it. And there is a shared joy. And that's amazing.
Yeah. Like to share joy with someone, like that should be our goal, right? Is to share joy. And I know your movie's going to do that for people.
And it's going to bring it to people who didn't get a chance to see it. I know. That to me is like the most important thing, you know? And I'm just really excited. And also I'm just, I'm excited again, like what you said, like for people to like go have that experience together and like go with their friends and make friends. And, and.
have this memory and go with their families.
And, you know, it's just like thinking about that is really, really special.
Anyway, sorry, Jenna, to bring that stuff up, but I just wanted to say that I'm, I feel very
inspired by you and very tender towards you.
Well, I actually appreciate you saying it.
It was well-timed because I just agreed to do a little bit of like a public service campaign,
and I was feeling a little nervous about it.
Wow.
That's a lot.
So thank you because, you know, I was nervous.
So I'm going to go into this campaign and I'm going to be fired up.
Oh my gosh.
Thanks to you.
Oh, God.
I'm glad.
You're amazing.
I'm...
Aw.
Everyone loves you.
Anyway.
All right.
Well, listen.
We have one more thing planned before you leave, which is that you have requested.
Yes, I have.
To do an office quiz.
With your friend Jack.
With my friend Jack.
Okay.
So let me explain really quick.
So my best friend, Alex, Wolf, he's an incredible actor.
He's wonderful.
And Alex, he has...
has another very best friend, and it's Jack Metzger, and he happens to be the J in the band
AJR, if you've heard of them. Anyway, I met him through Alex, and like at some point a couple
years ago, we met and we were around each other, and I knew he was out, my best friend's other
best friend who lived in New York, and I was like, oh, you're the other best friend, oh,
you know, and then they were like, well, actually Jack knows the office like better than anyone
in the world. And I was like, oh, hmm, interesting.
because no, he doesn't.
And I remember immediately having this feeling of like,
the hell, no, he doesn't.
And actually, instead of it making me like,
like we started talking about it,
and I felt seen for the first time in my way.
I was like, oh my God,
I've never met anyone who loves the office the way I do
until I met Jack.
And so we immediately became Best Budds.
And now he's like one of my favorite people in the world.
And anyway, all we do,
We have a group chat called Office Trivia.
He loves the Office as much as me and almost is as good as I am with the trivia.
Just the thing.
On that note, we're going to take a break.
And when we come back, we're going to have Jack and we're going to do Trivia.
Office trivia.
Okay.
Jack, like our like connection about this show has been life changing and.
I literally love you so much, seriously.
And so anyway, he's very nervous.
He wouldn't say it, but he's very nervous.
And he's trying to act cool, but he's really nervous.
How many times have you seen it?
Have you watched it a lot?
Honestly, I would say probably 20 times through.
Okay.
So do you have a favorite season or?
I'm probably going to go with season two.
Season two.
Respectable.
I like it.
Yep, season two.
I used to watch you when it first came on, first season on TV.
Oh, that's amazing.
Appointment television days.
Yeah.
Must see TV Thursdays.
All right.
Well, let's get this trivia going.
We're going to start with this.
It's the official office trivia board game.
It says, are you a true Dunderhead?
Whoa.
Dunderhead.
Let's find out.
I'm going to pick five from this deck randomly.
Here we go.
And then Jenna has a special surprise quiz.
Oh, my God.
But we're going to do.
Look at that.
We go. Official the office trivia game.
I'm scared.
Who told Michael to, quote, start over after Michael called him an idiot?
Darrell.
Oh, Darrell.
Oh, my gosh, right away.
Okay.
Who was the secretary of Knights of the Night?
Dwight.
Yes, softball.
Okay, that's like too easy.
It was confusing almost.
Whom did Dwight want to give a post-apocalypse, quote,
knapsack filled with canned goods, chainsaw, gasoline?
DeAngelo.
Yes, DiAngelo.
I couldn't even process what you're saying.
Oh my gosh, you got that so quick.
Okay.
Who became the receptionist and loved it while most of the office was in Florida?
Annie.
Yeah.
Okay.
Is that five?
That's four.
Here we go.
Who told Angela that the only premature baby in the room was the one her baby eight?
Oh.
Oh, oh.
What was the baby this baby eight?
Oscar.
Yeah.
God, I couldn't.
I haven't seen that episode in a while.
Okay.
You guys are five for five together.
of the official office trivia game.
But Jenna, are you ready to razzle-dazzle?
Okay, guys, we received an email
Oh, God.
Billy, that said you had requested, quote,
the hardest trivia we could think of.
Why?
We had a feeling that this board game
would be too easy.
So we asked one of the National Office Trivia Tournament winners
to write some questions for you both.
Okay.
This is my friend Will Allen,
who competes in the next year.
National Online Office Trivia Tournament with his team,
Who's Your Worm Guy?
At its peak, this competition was between over 700 teams from around the country.
His team won twice and placed in the top 10 over a dozen times.
So this is his pedigree, okay?
No pressure.
He says, quote, this is a very difficult quiz.
The easiest questions of this quiz would be final round questions in a hard office trivia tournament.
Oh, my God.
What are you doing? What are you doing?
Okay.
Question number one.
There are 18 toppings that make up the works.
God, damn it.
I knew this was going to happen.
Okay.
How many can you name?
All right.
Caramel drizzle, cotton candy bits.
Those, I'm like,
is there white chocolate chips?
There is not white chocolate chips.
Chocolate chips?
Failing already.
Is chocolate chips even in there?
Yes.
You have cotton candy bits, chocolate chip.
Okay, wait.
Chocolate chip.
Will said for a mild amount of respect, please name five.
Okay.
You got this.
I may give you a hint.
You have danced around a few of the words.
Chocolate.
Yes.
White chocolate.
Oh, okay.
Caramel drizzle.
Cotton candy bits.
Caramel.
Wait.
Caramel dip.
Thank you.
What the hell?
Wait, is there is a drizzle?
There is a drizzle.
I'm hearing the jizzle.
You definitely have named four.
Yes.
You have to name one more to get the point.
Sprinkles, no?
Sprinkles, yes.
Sprinkles is one.
Okay, so you got five.
Do you want to hear it?
We have the audio.
No, no, no, no.
Okay, wait.
Are you trying to get more?
I think five is respectable.
Angela?
I need silence.
Okay, okay.
Hold on.
Is there cinnamon sugar?
Yes.
Okay.
Cinnamon sugar.
That's my favorite.
Cinnamon sugar is really good on a pretzel.
Billy, are you attempting to go for all of them?
How many are there?
There's 18.
Are there nuts?
Yes, nuts is one.
Oh, nuts.
There's no powdered sugar, is there?
Yes.
Yes, there is.
That's the last one.
I think that is the last one.
And powdered sugar, remember?
Yeah.
Yep, that is.
Okay.
You one, two, three, four, five, six, seven, eight, nine, ten.
It's pretty good.
I'm going to play the audio clip.
Here it is, everybody.
Hi, please tell me you have a sweet pretzel left.
We do.
Thank God.
And we have 18 different toppings.
We have sweet glaze, cinnamon sugar, chocolate, white chocolate, fudge, M&Ms, caramel dip, mint chip, chocolate chip, marshmallows, nuts, toffee nuts, coconut, coconut, peanut, peanut, peanut, butter, drizzle, Oreo, sprinkles, cotton candy bits, and powdered sugar.
Is there any way that you could do all, all of them?
The works, you got it.
All right.
Thank you.
Peanut butter drizzle?
Peanut butter drizzle.
It works. You got it.
All right.
Do you want me to continue with this quiz?
Okay.
Question number two.
Can you name all of the candy bars that Michael references in his business school lecture?
Payday.
Yes.
$100 grand.
Snickers?
Yes.
I'm going to let him do this one.
There's one more.
You know it really, right?
Yeah.
Wait.
There's one more.
Who's or what's it?
No, no.
You're so close.
A thing I'm a jig.
What can I call it?
It's it.
Watch your call it.
What you call it.
You got it.
Okay.
When Creed is the interim manager, he calls a meeting where he splits the office into two groups for team building.
Elroy.
Which Dundermifflin employee is somehow listed in both groups and which person named does not actually work there.
Okay.
Elroy.
That's correct.
Doesn't exist.
But there's one person who's listed in both groups.
So he names Phyllis.
That's it.
Oh.
Phyllis and Elroy.
Because he says Phyllis and Elroy.
So that's the answer.
I did not know about it.
Okay.
Do you want more?
Yes.
Okay.
I want everything.
And then we can do a speed round of the normal game.
Okay.
And get every single question and then feel a little better about ourselves.
I like that.
When Pam and Andy are stuck working together,
they visit an office park to attempt some in-person business acquisitions.
I don't know how you would know this, but what company conducts business in Sweet 202?
My gosh.
Dean Trophies Sweet 202.
Oh, wait.
Sherman Bines and Rock.
Yes.
Sherman Blines and Rocks.
Sherman Blinds and Rock Sweet 202.
You wouldn't have got it if we didn't sing it.
That was so good.
That was great.
And then there's like a Dean Trophy's Sweet 100 and Doodily Doe or something like that.
Yeah.
Doodle do.
That sounds like Andy.
And then sweet, food.
Four of one.
Yeah.
Besides the United States
where Dwight would originally steal
the Tiffany Chandelier,
what are the four other countries
involved in this heist?
Okay.
Canada is one, right?
Mexico?
Yeah.
France, yes.
France.
You only need one more.
Is it somewhere random?
No, it's somewhere that might be
part of Dwight's family of origin.
Oh, that's a huge hint.
Germany?
Yes.
Huck.
Oh, wow.
Jenna gave me that one.
What is my perfect crime?
I break into Tiffany's in midnight.
Do I go for the vault?
No, I go for the chandelier.
It's priceless.
As I'm taking it down, a woman catches me.
She tells me to stop.
It's her father's business.
She's Tiffany.
We make love all night.
In the morning, the cops come, and I escape in one of their uniforms.
I tell her to meet me in Mexico, but I go to Canada.
I don't trust her.
Besides, I like the cold.
30 years later, I get a postcard.
I have a son.
And he's the chief of police.
This is where the story gets interesting.
I tell Tiffany to meet me in Paris by the Trocadero.
She's been waiting for me all these years.
She's never taken another lover.
I don't care.
I don't show up.
I go to Berlin.
That's where I stashed the chandelier.
Oh, Berlin.
That's why these are like final questions because he says Paris and Berlin,
he doesn't say France and Germany, but he says Mexico and Canada.
Oh.
They ask for countries.
See, they're tricky.
They are tricky.
To give us some credit, Jack, these are questions in the final round of the final, what did you call it?
National Office trivia championship.
Come on.
We're doing good for that.
Over 700 teams have competed to get to this moment.
I mean, that's insane.
I have a question for you guys.
Yes.
This is not trivia.
This is just a fun one.
This is what we would call our office question of the week.
This is from Lena C in Germany who says,
which invention of Michael Scott do you think could actually be successful in real life if you had to pick one?
Would you pick Shulala, chair pants, toilet buddy, Mike Serial Shack, or Threat Level Midnight, the movie?
I really like Mike Serial Shack.
That's very intriguing to me.
Also, it's a really cute name.
Yeah.
The pants chair.
Honestly, I remember watching it being like, this is like 1% a good idea.
Yeah, if there was a way to make the chair pants like not uncomfortable to walk around in, where it was like totally normal pants.
But then if you sat down, it became a chair.
You know, as a parent who is often going to like kids sporting events, where there isn't a chair.
if I could just wear my chair pants.
Yeah, right?
Really, you guys, I am surprised
no one has chosen toilet buddy.
You don't want to go to the bathroom
through a strainer?
I think there's...
Just so your stuff doesn't fall in.
That is one of my favorite Michael moments.
It was deleted.
It was added back to the super fan episode.
You can see it in all its glory.
Is there anything else, Jack,
that we need to do in terms of trivia?
Do you want three rapid fire from...
Okay, three rapid fire.
Let's be easy.
It's the most fun thing ever.
So yeah.
Okay, okay.
This is a really rapid fire.
Ready?
Okay.
On the wall of Mr. Chu's Chinese restaurant, who was in a photo holding up a sign that said thief?
Breed.
Yep.
Who did Dwight think takes 50 minutes to style his hair?
Yes.
Jim.
Okay.
Sorry, I couldn't even read the question.
All right.
One more.
Who was only a little stitious?
Michael.
Yay.
Can't get enough.
We clearly could do this all damn day because it's so fun.
Jack, love you so much.
Thank you for getting on.
I literally love you so much.
I'm honored to meet you guys.
Thanks so much for having me.
Jack, you're amazing at trivia.
You guys should enter a competition.
By the way, he also has a whole song about the office and how his life and relationships
have just completely been told through the story of the office throughout his life.
And it's out and you can listen to it.
What is the name of this song?
What is the name of the song?
A Netflix trip.
I know it.
I know that song.
I think you guys have actually talked about it.
We've talked about it.
We played it on the podcast.
Oh, did you really?
I think I played it.
Yeah.
That's you?
That's me and my brothers.
Yeah, yeah.
Oh, my God.
Yes, it's so wonderful.
I want to play some of it.
I had my forest crush in season two.
She passed me notes and fill our hands with glue.
Aww
To school
I sat and crossed my legs like chin would do
Aww
She moved away
I was on season three
It hit my heart so hard I'd have me speak
But I could find some peace in privacy
A paper company to sell with me
still with me. So sweet. Thank you guys so much. And that's awesome. You guys have both written songs.
It's true. With the office. It's true. And the office themes. That's kind of, it wouldn't be who we are without the show.
It's pretty cool. We wouldn't be friends without the office. It bonded us. Well, listen, we always are humbled by the fact that our show brings people together.
And I know you feel that way about your music, both of you. And thank you so much for taking the time to come here
today. We love you guys. We love you. We want you to come back anytime you want. For real.
No, seriously, you have to stop saying that because you don't want me to come back so many because I'm going to literally...
You know what you should do? You tell us an episode that you want to break down with us. And we'll break down an episode with you.
You can pick a super fan. Oh, my God, done. Literally done. Let's do it.
Yeah. There we go. All right. Thank you for coming.
Bye guys. Bye. Wow. I know. I still can't believe it happened. I still can't get over the fact that she is such a
a big office ladies fan.
She's also just a wonderful human being.
Yes.
And such a fun person to be around.
And just gives her all to you.
I know.
I just, I really like her as a person.
Yeah.
I mean, she is so accomplished and so talented,
but she's also just a fantastic human being.
Yeah.
And super smart.
Oh, and I really loved her dog shark.
He tried to eat the granola bar in my back.
But next time I'll bring treats.
Okay, Billy.
you come back, we're going to have treats for Shark.
I also want to give a big thank you to Will Allen for helping me prepare our office
trivia quiz. And I want to give a shout out because Will is currently starring as Dr. Thomas Stockman
and Amy Herzog's adaptation of an enemy of the people at the stunning new timeline
theater in Chicago. You can get tickets at timelinetheater.com. I saw this in New York.
It's a great show. And also, we would love to thank Jack Metzker for calling in
to do trivia with Billy, and that was so cool to find out that he wrote the song
Netflix trip about his love of The Office. I know. I couldn't believe that. I'm like,
I know that song. You're like, it's you. And oh my goodness, thank you so much to Billy Eilish
for being an office ladies, listener and fan. I hope you like this episode, Billy. Hi.
Hi, Billy. How are you doing? Are you listening to us right now? Are you in your house?
Maybe hanging some pictures. I know. Are you cleaning up something, maybe folding laundry?
Maybe you're just in the car.
We don't know.
Yeah.
All right.
Thanks, everyone.
We will be back next week with a very special guest from the Office cast.
We're going to be chatting with Calvin Tenor who played Glenn from the warehouse.
All right.
See you then.
Thank you for listening to Office Ladies.
Office Ladies is a presentation of Odyssey and is produced by Jenna Fisher and Angela Kinsey.
Our senior producer is Matt Beagle and our audio engineer is Sam Pfeiffer.
Odyssey's executive producer is Leah Reese Dennis.
Office Ladies was mixed in.
mastered by Bill Schultz.
Our theme song is Ruppertry by Creed Bratton.
Hey y'all, it's Kelly Clarkson with Wayfair.
Ever order furniture online and wonder, what if?
Like, what if it doesn't hold up?
That sofa was four days old.
You should have ordered from Wayfair.
With Wayfair, there's no what if.
Just style you love and quality you can trust.
Visit Wayfair.ca.
Wayfair, every style, every home.